[Music]
most stars in hollywood dream of one day
being in a franchise where their
character gets to enjoy cult status and
then there's keanu reeves he has done it
twice once as neo in the matrix and
sometime later is john wick now it has
been three years since the third part of
the film series came out in theaters but
it has been obvious for a long time that
the story around the retired hitman is
not over yet unfortunately the stresses
and strains of the recent years
repeatedly forced the producers to
postpone the premiere of a fourth
chapter finally a date seems to have
been set and that is march 24 2023
meaning that it's high time for us to
check out the upcoming film and perhaps
take another look at what happened in
the last few installments in addition we
have summarized everything important
related to the cast plot and production
for you in this video
first of all let's take a look at the
past to recall the main events this is
where we give you the inevitable spoiler
warning if you haven't seen the last
movies you should rather skip forward to
the next section now after losing his
beloved wife helen to a terminal illness
the widower john wick is given a cute
little beagle as a final gift from her
so to speak daisy as john is named the
dog unfortunately does not have a long
life ahead of her after the professional
killer is approached by a group of young
russians at a gas station and rejects
their offer to buy his beautiful mustang
they feel offended and want to pay him
back by stealing the valuable possession
unfortunately the dog dies in the
process and after the criminals take
away not only his car but also his last
memento of his wife john wick vows
revenge by the end of the 101 minute
bloodbath the vendetta is complete
finally in an animal clinic it sort of
comes to a happy ending because there he
saves a dog from being euthanized and
goes for a walk with the young pitbull
puppy john wick chapter 2 is set just a
few days after the first movie in this
one john is asked to redeem a so-called
blood oath the mission does not go as
planned and jon is seriously injured
with the help of the bowery king john is
patched up given a weapon and the exact
location of his adversary centino
d'antonio after a tense battle between
john and centino which ends in the
assassin's refuge continental john
forbiddenly shoots the antagonist right
on the spot as a result the mafia
increases the bounty to 14 million
dollars causing john to lose his
privileges and access to the
underworld's resources john wick chapter
3 also picks up directly from his
predecessor and initially shows john on
the run through new york city in search
of the elder of the high table john must
wander through the desert until he can
no longer walk as one of the members
instructs jon eventually finds himself
collapsing from exhaustion in the desert
and indeed he is found there by the
elders henchmen and then brought to him
the elder demands the death of
continental boss winston and so john
makes his way back to new york after
winston betrays him he is shot and falls
from the roof of the hotel john who is
severely injured escapes back to the
bowery king who is neither well disposed
towards the high table after having been
mutilated so much for all the bloody
action until the end of the third film
and all of this is just due to a russian
gangster who had the idea to murder john
wick's dog well that was a huge mistake
the john wick series is known for its
cool and deadly characters so what can
we look forward to in john wick chapter
4. let's take a moment to talk about the
cast of the film and the old as well as
the new characters
first and foremost of course there is
jonathan john wick himself arguably the
world's most popular killer continues to
be played by one of the world's most
popular actors that being keanu reeves
there is nothing but love for the
friendly neighborhood assassin as he did
not start the bloodshed himself but
merely took revenge for his sweet dog
and let's be honest who among us
wouldn't do the same for their
four-legged friend so far he's killed no
less than 306 people in the first three
movies leaving most of the other killers
far behind well maybe with the exception
of marvel's thanos but our anti-hero has
of course not survived entirely
unscathed be it shot stabbed in the
stomach injured by bottles or thrown out
of a building in the end he always
managed to stand up again fix his always
well-fitted suit and look for his next
target
as john's first ex-companion we have to
deal with winston played by ian mcshane
the latter turned on him at the end of
chapter three and shot him several times
until he fell off the continental this
brought the continental back to its old
status and winston back to his old job
whether he intended to kill him or was
aware that he would survive it is not
really clear at the end but after the
adjudicator leaves winston seems to be
smiling and says baba yaga this suggests
that he may know exactly what happened
to jon who just barely survived the fall
and was taken to the bowery king and
this is who we will deal with next the
bowery king is played by lawrence
fishburn which surely put some smiles on
the faces of many matrix fans back then
seeing neo and morpheus face each other
again after such a long time in a
completely different world his real name
is not known and may remain a secret
forever the bowery king compares jon's
injuries to his own and asks him whether
he's angry with the high table after jon
answers in the affirmative he reveals
that he will wage a war against the high
table for wrongfully punishing him and
killing his men jon makes it clear that
he intends to join his war and thus the
groundwork for chapter four is laid a
little side fact the name bowery king is
an allusion to the middle ages
apparently there used to be beggar kings
who got information from vagrants and
homeless people and sold it on similar
to what lord varus did in game of
thrones finally of course we can't do
without lance reddick as chairman he is
the concierge of the hotel in winston's
right-hand man he takes care of all
kinds of tasks in the hotel and also
offers jon all sorts of services for
example taking care of his dog or
shooting people down if he has to
in each part there were also all sorts
of new bounty hunters who were out to
get john this is of course also the case
in john wick 4 thereby we will also see
some faces which we know from other
martial arts movies let's start with the
lesser-known names first we have rina
sawayama in the role of akira sawayama
is mostly known for being a singer and a
model she has made the occasional
appearance on late night shows however
john wick 4 will be her very first film
then scott adkins is best known for many
second-tier action movies and will play
a character named killa here the british
actor and martial artist works not only
as an actor but also as a stunt man
since 1998 he has participated in about
60 productions the most famous among
them should be the expendables 2 doctor
strange and ip man 4. as the third
newcomer we have shamier anderson called
tracker in the film the 31 year old has
been acting in rather small productions
for 10 years therefore the film may also
serve as a stepping stone for him
another martial arts artist signed on is
marco zarror in the role of chidi in
addition to his own acting roles he has
often worked as a stunt double for
dwayne the rock johnson these were the
four less known faces in the movie now
let's move on to the old hands first we
have the young swede bill skarsgard he
will play a character called marquise
his probably biggest role was the clown
pennywise in it there was also part of
marvel's eternals and with hiroyuki
sonata the filmmakers were able to
secure one of the best-known japanese
actors in john wick chapter 4 he will
slip into the role of shimazu whether
it's bullet train mortal kombat end game
or the wolverine sonata has appeared in
all kinds of major productions over the
past 20 years either as a sidekick or as
an antagonist with donnie yen the
producers were able to bring in another
star from the east the ip man star plays
a bounty hunter named kane yen gained
great notoriety in the past 10 years
primarily in the role of wing chun
master ip man and of course in rogue one
a star wars story as the fighting monk
chirit imwe due to his achievements in
recent years in 2017 he was even
admitted to the academy of motion
picture arts and sciences the
organization that annually awards the
oscars the final well-known actress we
have is natalia tenna in the role of
katja most of you will know tenna for
playing the or nymphadora tanks from
harry potter her last major television
role was in the mandalorian in 2019 we
still have one big name for you but her
role name in the film is not yet known
clancy brown will also be involved in
the film the 1.92 meter tall giant
became known in the role of kurgan in
highlander from 1986 since then he has
participated in well over 200
productions as an actor or voice actor
his last role was in the rather unknown
movie last looks in 2021
as always as long as the filmmakers
remain silent it is not that easy to
talk about the plot at least keanu
reeves himself presented the first
teaser trailer for the movie at the
comic con in san diego besides a lot of
action the trailer shows jon training
hard for his vendetta with the bowery
king at the end the king of the homeless
even shows up with a fresh suit and asks
jon whether he's ready anyhow it's clear
that the two will be hunting down the
high table and it's 12 bosses from the
looks of the trailer these will include
clancy brown and skarsgard's character
another interesting aspect will be the
roles of winston and charon both have
obviously turned against jon but whether
they really still work for the high
table is unclear after all the latter
would have sacrificed the continental
and winston without batting an eye it
will also be particularly exciting to
delve deeper into the character of the
bowery king and his empire or rather
what is left of it for one thing should
be clear he and jon can only move in the
shadows now in the trailer akira tracker
and shimazu seem to be on jon's side
mainly because jon and shimasu fight
together against donnie yen as kane who
either works for or with marquise about
the other newcomers unfortunately no
information is known yet director chad
stahelski also spoke a bit about the
plot in the end of the film in an
interview he emphasized that the fourth
film will definitely end on a very
emotional level it will also bring some
story lines to a close this does not
mean that it will be the final part
since in addition to a fifth film a
prequel is also being planned in the
form of the miniseries the continental
we hope to find out more about the plot
soon one thing is for sure though there
will surely be no lack of action
the new movie was already confirmed back
in may 2019 and chad stahlski will once
again take up his position in the
director's chair incidentally he was
kiana reeves stunt double in the first
matrix film and was recently allowed to
be beaten up by trinity in part four of
the sci-fi series as the unpleasant
husband chad thus both the director and
the lead actor share a friendship that
has lasted for years and we think that
shows in the john wick series in
december 2019 reeves began gun foo
training in preparation for filming both
the 4th john wick movie and matrix
resurrections a preview of his progress
could already be seen in the trailer
there was a sequence with donnie yen in
which the two of them showed off the
combination of hand-to-hand combat and
firearms after a long period of delay
shooting them again on june 28 2021 at
studio babelsberg in potsdam as well as
in berlin in paris a mere five months
later filming was officially concluded
it is also known that a fifth part is
already being worked upon lionsgate ceo
john feldheimer announced that the
script has already been in development
since august 2020 stahelski by the way
told the hollywood reporter his secret
for the series success he claimed that
john wick simply has to be made to
suffer in the interview he stated we
keep finding new and interesting ways to
have john wick suffer that's where the
action comes from figure out how to make
him suffer and then design backward in
retrospect this is a very smart approach
alright that was all the latest news
about the fourth part of john wick which
new actor are you looking forward to the
most and how do you think the whole
movie will end let us know in the
comments section and if you like this
video please feel free to give it a
thumbs up see you next time
[Music]